the North American Air Defense command
known as NORAD was established in 1958
it was to provide early warning and
defense against Soviet bombers and
missile launches but it wasn't long
before NORAD would be monitoring Skies
around the entire planet early in the
morning on January 13 1996 NORAD
contacted Brazilian air defense to
report an object entering the Earth's
atmosphere about 200 miles Northeast of
Sao Paulo when asked what type of object
NORAD said it was unidentified a few
minutes later it crashed somewhere near
the town of Virginia the Brazilian Army
and Air Force quickly scrambled to get
to the crash site before any civilians
did but they were too late the craft was
seen and the beings driving the craft
were gone over the next few days a
series of events would unfold that would
change the lives of the people in the
area forever well at least the lives of
the people who survived
[Music]
Virginia is located what I'm looking at
that word in a teleprompter and oh I see
her I thought I said it doesn't right
right okay so the town is vagina go on
Virginia fine whatever just do me a
favor put the name of the town in the
thumbnail all right it'll definitely get
clicks it probably would like uh how
about strange object at this vagina
Virginia oh a mysterious vagina Virginia
they are pretty mysterious
Virginia is in the southern region of
the Brazilian state of mina Shiraz its
population of about 135 000 makes it one
of the largest cities in the region its
economy is mostly based on agriculture
coffee corn and soybeans are the main
crops grown on the many farms that
surround the city one of those Farms is
owned by eureko and orolina de Freitas
it was early in the morning before
Sunrise when orolina heard the cows
running around the property sounding
agitated she looked out the window and
saw hovering above the pasture a
cigar-shaped object she grabbed her
husband Eureka they said the shape of it
reminded them of a submarine and there's
about the size of a school minibus the
object was billowing white smoke and
seemed to have trouble maneuvering the
two watched the craft for an hour before
it disappeared over a ridge not far from
the farm on the other side of that Ridge
Carlos de Souza was driving to the
airport when he heard a strange muffled
rumbling he thought something was wrong
with his truck so he stopped then he
realized the sound was coming from a
cigar-shaped craft about 300 feet in the
air and it was losing altitude the
object had Windows along the side and
what appeared to be a long crack running
through the middle of it out of the
crack white smoke was pouring out Carlos
thought this was strange because the
smoke from a fire or an engine failure
would be black the rumbling sound made
by the craft occasionally sputtered it
was clearly struggling to stay in the
air Carlos jumped back in his truck and
followed it it eventually passed over
some small mountains went into a steep
dive and disappeared after a few minutes
Carlos found a dirt road that led to the
area where it went down he came over the
crest of a hill and saw wreckage spread
out over a wide area Carlos began
running to the crash site which was a
few hundred feet from the road at first
he thought it was a small plane he was a
pilot himself so if there was a crash he
wanted to help but it only took him a
few steps to realize this was no plane
oh
in the air was a heavy stench of ammonia
and sulfur like sour rotten eggs deodor
was so strong that he had to wrap his
shirt around his mouth to breathe and
even then the smell stung his eyes and
made them water debris was everywhere
pieces of metal that look like aluminum
but even lighter Carlos grabbed a large
sheath that had almost no weight to it
it looked like aluminum foil they
crumpled the sheet and dropped it as
soon as he released it the metal
unfolded and went back into its original
shape and then floated to the ground
like a feather Carlos started making his
way toward the larger pieces of debris
to search for survivors but before he
could take more than a few steps the
rumbling of trucks caught his attention
a convoy of military vehicles tore
across the field and began establishing
a perimeter Soldiers with guns raised
shouted for Carlos to get away Carlos
briefly protested but only briefly he
was staring down the barrel of a rifle
not six inches from his face when he
raised his hands and slowly backed away
shaking can Carlos left the scene and
stopped to grab a cup of coffee to try
and collect himself after a few minutes
two men approached Carlos described them
as tall and neatly dressed in dark suits
yep the men told Carlos that they know
who he is and where he lives they know
his wife his daughter they told him that
he's to forget everything that he saw
and never speak of it Carlos was
terrified he nodded that he understood
then the strangers got into a black car
with no license plates and drove away
Carlos would keep what he saw a secret
for 26 years meanwhile back at the crash
site the Brazilian military was hard at
work Gathering the wreckage the craft
was definitely big enough to hold a
small crew so the order went out to
search for survivors there were
survivors but the soldiers wouldn't find
them at least not near the crash those
survivors were already in town
just a few hours after the crash
authorities started receiving strange
reports from residents in the area at
about 8 A.M a college student reported
seeing a creature with oily dark brown
skin crouched in an Alleyway near a
local park he said it had very small
hands with three long fingers it was
between four and five feet tall and had
no hair or clothing yeah you noticed
aliens are always naked I guess that's
true respect what yeah I don't know how
you humans do with pants I
it'll all hang out okay that's enough
rude just a few blocks away three young
women Lillian valkyria and Katya were on
their way to the same park they took a
shortcut through a vacant lot there in
the Tall Grass huddled next to a cinder
block wall was
a creature it was about four feet tall
and had a large head on its head were
three bumps or ridges it had huge red
eyes its skin was brown and looked shiny
or oily it had a slim frail body and no
hair and no clothes respect the girls
weren't sure what this thing was but
when they approached it looked right at
them the girls were frozen in fear
unable to move or speak though it made
no sound the girls were able to hear
this being or feel its thoughts they
could feel that it was frightened in
pain and needed help the girls tore out
of there terrified they burst into
Katie's house and told her mother that
they had seen a demon before them
returned to the lot but the creature was
gone however katya's mother found a
strange footprint it wasn't a human
footprint whatever this thing was its
feet had three long toes the girls
described the creature to an artist who
created this now famous picture
even though the creature was gone there
was a heavy odor of ammonia that
lingered God his mother said she
couldn't get the smell out of her nose
for days a few hours later military
policeman Eric Lopes and Marco Shiraz
were patrolling the area suddenly a
small humanoid creature with dark skin
darted across the street Marco jumped
out of the car and managed to grab it
they restrained the creature and rushed
it to the hospital where according to
reports it died almost immediately Marco
started feeling ill he said his skin
felt greasy even though it wasn't and
there was a lingering smell of ammonia
that stayed with him over the next two
weeks his condition worsened and he was
admitted to the hospital and placed in
intensive care none of the doctors could
figure out what was wrong with him or
how to help finally at the age of 23
Marco sherez died of an unknown cause
the doctors said an autopsy wasn't
necessary and ordered a closed casket
service they also had his body buried
immediately they said this was to
protect Public Health they did make his
blood tests available his blood
contained eight percent of unknown toxic
substances
and that was the first death caused by
the Virginia UFO incident
but it wasn't the last
several calls came into the fire
department about a wild animal on the
loose near the park where the girls saw
the creature four firemen were
dispatched to look for it when the
firemen arrived on the scene there were
five civilians watching the creature
that had gone down a steep embankment
toward a densely wooded area they said
it made a buzzing sound similar to bees
it took the firemen two hours to capture
it it kept running away and the terrain
was hard to navigate and they were
afraid of whatever this thing was
everyone who saw it said it gave off a
strong offensive odor like ammonia and
sulfur finally the firemen were able to
snare the creature in a net by now a
military truck arrived from ASA a
military base a few miles away Witnesses
saw soldiers struggling with two black
bags one bag was squirming as if
something was alive in it but the other
bag was still the bags were heaved into
the truck and It sped away immediately
the area was surrounded by military
vehicles and civilians were not allowed
in or out of the area less than an hour
later section of regional hospital was
ordered locked down then 10 military and
police vehicles arrived the truck then
pulled up close to the entrance and Two
Soldiers unloaded a black body bag the
bag was taken to the radiology
department for x-rays the x-ray
technician on duty that day said the
examination room was full of doctors
police and military personnel people
were nervous and just staring at each
other afraid to speak the tech was
ordered to take X-rays of the bag which
he wasn't allowed to open he did this
but then the military took the film The
Radiologists never saw the pictures he
said he'd never experienced anything
like that before or since he was told to
keep everything he seen a secret as a
matter of National Security then as
quickly as they arrived the military
Entourage left with the x-rays and the
body bag but the smell of ammonia and
sulfur remained the text said the smell
felt like it was inside his nose and
lingered in fact that whole section of
the hospital was closed to the public
for another three or four days no no
matter what the cleaning staff did they
couldn't remove the smell they just had
to wait for it to dissipate by the way
one of the firemen who helped capture
the alien died a few weeks later from
unknown toxic poisoning
senior military officials warned
everyone involved 50 doctors and
Hospital staff were put under strict
non-disclosure agreements and told this
was a training exercise the doctors and
nurses were threatened with prison if
they ever spoke about what happened
soldiers were reminded of their
responsibilities to National Security
and that if they spoke about what
happened it could be considered treason
these tactics worked because after the
military convoys sped away from the
hospital there wouldn't be any new
details about the story where the truck
went what was in it who was involved
nothing but 25 years later a witness
would come forward and he would reveal
details that nobody saw coming
[Music]
foreign it took 25 years but a soldier
came forward who was close to everything
his testimony can be seen in the
excellent documentary on this case
moment of contact by filmmaker James Fox
and if you want to learn more about the
story I recommend you check it out and
there's a link below the soldier who
came forward refused to allow his name
to be used so he became known as
military X but I found a very old report
from Virginia local news which revealed
his name now I don't want to out the
guys so we'll just call him Raul which
is close to his real first name Raul was
part of the Convoy that brought the
creature to the hospital and there he
saw the alien in a box it was covered
but it was between four and five feet
tall he was able to see his foot poking
out he said its skin was very dark red
or brown and looked oily he knew this
wasn't human because its foot had only
three toes from the hospital they went
to the as a military base about 20 miles
from Virginia after they parked the
trucks Raul and another Soldier were
called into the base Commander's office
their CEO asked them what they saw Raul
was frightened and not sure how to
answer he said he thought he saw a burnt
man or something like that his
commanding officer told him that's not
what you saw you saw something
Supernatural Raul was told that if he
reveals what he saw to anyone the
consequences would be severe
the following day was very strange at
the base there were Navy trucks and
helicopters there which was unusual
there was a lot of activity a lot of
unfamiliar faces people were on edge
early that morning Raul and the Convoy
left Aza and went to a SpaceX army base
in Campinas about two hours away what
they went from vagina to the penis
tomato Virginia Virginia the algorithm
is going to punish you for this one well
they are now
Raul didn't know what happened to the
creature though he had heard rumors
rumors that would turn out to be true
Jose Manuel Fernandez was an air traffic
controller at the base during this time
he said two helicopters left the base
went to Virginia and returned with what
he didn't know but he thought it was
some kind of Rescue Mission then
something happened that Jose had never
experienced a large plane was coming in
but it didn't have authorization to land
Jose supervisors told him to allow it
anyway the plane landed and boxes were
loaded onto it then it took off again
and that was it the trucks the
helicopters and all the extra people
just left Jose asked what this was all
about and he was told it was a secret
mission and that was all he needed to
know but Jose does remember what kind of
plane land he called it a yousoft plane
what kind of a plane is a use of well
that's what Brazilians call it usop or
USAF
the United States Air Force
foreign
that's agreed on by the witnesses from
the military is that the United States
immediately took over the operation
whatever the operation was even though
the American plane came and went very
quickly there were a few Americans who
stayed behind a few months after the
events katya's mother Donna Luisa heard
a knock on the door she opened it and
four men shoved their way in she
described them as foreigners neatly
dressed in dark suits and pushy one held
a clipboard the other carried a
briefcase they told her that they were
there to make a proposal she could take
all the money in the briefcase which was
tens of thousands of dollars in cash in
return she convinces the girls to
retract their story and admit they made
the whole thing up then they leave the
country and never speak of these things
again she refused they insisted that she
take the money and be silent Donald
Louisa said the girls did see something
out there and she wouldn't have them
portrayed as Liars again the men
insisted as they continued to press the
issue they became very frustrated and
Donna Luisa started to become frightened
she told the men to leave her house or
she would call the police finally and
very suddenly they left another
well-respected family just a few blocks
away reported seeing an object in the
sky on the evening the aliens were
captured they said the object was the
size of a bus circular and metallic it
hovered just a few hundred feet above
their house and though it was rotating
very quickly the object was completely
silent they said it was traveling slowly
back and forth like it was looking for
something after they made their report
two men paid them a visit they asked a
lot of questions and talked to the
family for hours and just before the
strangers left they said what you saw
didn't happen and this conversation
never happened they implied that if they
spoke publicly it would be very bad for
the family and to this day the family
insists that this entire story happened
but they refused to give their names a
key to this entire story is Eric Lopes
he was the partner of Marco Shiraz the
young military policeman who died after
touching the alien Lopes is one of the
only people alive who can confirm the
story he was there when the alien was
captured it was in his car when they
drove into the hospital and he helped
carry it in for 25 years he's refused to
speak about the incident when James Fox
and his crew showed up at his house to
ask him about what happened he was so
agitated he threatened to shoot them if
they didn't leave him alone
the Virginia UFO incident has been
called the Brazilian Roswell it's
considered to be the most compelling
case for UFOs and aliens in history
or is it
the Virginia UFO incident became a world
famous case in 1996 and with a
documentary moment of contact being
released it's once again on people's
minds but how much of the story is true
well this is a difficult case to prove
and disprove the fact is there's not a
single piece of physical evidence to
support that any of this happened the
entire story is based on witness
testimony testimony that over the years
has been less than consistent you'll
hear some documentaries say that the
witnesses have no reason to lie because
they haven't made any money for their
story that's not true quite a few
Witnesses have been compensated over the
years in fact the Wall Street Journal
reported that the girls who found the
creature wouldn't give an interview for
anything less than two hundred dollars
something they later denied about those
girls it's important to know that there
was no Virginia UFO incident before the
girl's story was made public it was only
after they recovered on a popular TV
program that other Witnesses came
forward and those Witness this is
describe the aliens the same way the
girls did so the new Witnesses either
saw the same alien or they were lying
and building on other stories they heard
there's no way to know for sure but when
the girls reported the creature they
never said it was an alien there was no
mention of a UFO they thought the
creature looked like a demon at the time
all this was happening people in the
area were obsessed with a Cryptid called
chupacabra which was getting a lot of
coverage it was a local UFO researcher
who proposed that what they saw was an
alien the official explanation is that
the girls actually saw someone locals
called mudino mudino means little mute
his real name is Luis Antonio de Paula
he was a mentally and physically
disabled man who would spend hours
crouching and looking at small objects
on the ground he lived where the girls
saw the alien in fact he still lives
there he doesn't live near the location
he lives at the location the day they
saw him there was a major storm passing
through the area so much rain fell that
some parts of the Town were flooded it
could be that modinio was covered in mud
which was known to happen and he scared
the girls but the girls say that it
couldn't have been mudino because they
know him and wouldn't mistake him for an
alien but in the original report they
said they didn't know him and when they
first saw him they thought he looked
like a demon they said the same thing
about the alien they may or may not be
lying intentionally but one of their
versions of the story is wrong and this
isn't surprising it's a 26 year old case
witness reports are all over the place
this was a huge story in 1996 it made
international news people's memories
change over time if you read an
interesting detail about this case you
may even unknowingly add that detail to
your version of the story tell that
story enough times your brain will
actually create a false memory to
support it when katya's mother first
told the story about the men trying to
bribe her to get her daughters to
retract their story
said they implied there would be a
payment later the story included a
briefcase full of cash now did she
forget this detail early on or had she
been hearing stories about the Men in
Black for so long that the briefcase
found its way into her memory side note
the weather conditions make it unlikely
that anyone saw an alien footprint in
the mod but who knows stories vary some
witnesses gave statements that they
later denied others denied seeing
anything but then later came forward and
other witness reports don't fit the
timeline at all the couple who first saw
the UFO over their Farm they said it
happened a week earlier it's possible
they aren't remembering correctly but if
I saw UFO hovering over my house for an
hour I'd remember every detail about
that day memories are stored with
emotion the more emotional the event the
more likely you are to recall it people
who live through the JFK assassination
or the 911 attack know exactly where
they were when they heard the news
people vividly remember the days their
children are born and vividly remember
when their parents died emotions create
memories now about Marco shirez the
young officer who died after touching
the alien it said that he was perfectly
healthy and suddenly became ill that's
not true he had a cysts on his arm that
became infected the cyst was documented
well before any of this happened Marco
wasn't connected to the UFO story until
much later and his sister was the first
person to bring it up now she says it
happened and that's that but her earlier
story said it was possible he was
involved though she didn't know for sure
the Brazilian military released a report
of these events that was over a thousand
pages long according to the report Marco
wasn't even working that night the
retort also says all the military
vehicles in the area were part of a
training exercise as a base was a
training base the military convoys were
just Vehicles all going in for schedule
maintenance at the same time which they
do after all the base is just a few
miles away the hospital Wing was closed
but that was because they had to make it
sterile enough for new cardiac equipment
that was being being delivered by the
way that equipment was delivered in
stainless steel Boxes by the military
the body bag was a recently exhumed
cadaver that was part of a police
investigation what people thought were
aliens at the hospital were actually a
dwarf couple there to have a baby and
they were helped in by a soldier now
some of those facts sound perfectly
reasonable to me others like the
pregnant dwarf not so much but that's
part of the story it's all a cover-up
the military altered the records after
the fact they even gave a very sketchy
press conference about this
[Music]
I strongly
the progress here
is General Lima covering up he acts like
it but if there really wasn't anything
weird about this incident the general
would be pretty irritated that he'd have
to deal with any of this so how you read
him and any of the witnesses really
comes down to your point of view and
toward which side you lean skeptic or
believer if you watch James Fox's moment
of contact some of the Witnesses are
compelling in the case of Marco de Souza
the man who found the craft in the field
he's so overcome that he breaks down
into tears okay
[Music]
I kill
you
[Applause]
serious Warheads
foreign
[Music]
he should leave Brazil and move to
Hollywood Fox gets statements not just
from local residents but from doctors
and people in the military they all say
it happened and they give Vivid details
about what they saw yes some people
won't talk others talk but with their
faces blurred and voices changed but
some people put their names and faces
out there for everyone to see that's
been so long that these people could be
misremembering but they don't come
across as Liars but there's no way to
tell if what they're saying is true
there is one man who could settle this
entire case once and for all Eric Lopes
he was driving the car when Marcos
shirez captured the alien he saw
everything but he's willing to shoot
people who want to talk to him about
this is he afraid or is he an old angry
man living in poverty who's sick of
people bothering him about this if he
came forward to confirm that Marco did
capture an alien then the entire
official story unravels and you could
throw away that thousand page Army
report and you can start rewriting
history because Eric Lopes is one of the
few people on the face of the planet who
could confirm 100 without a doubt that
aliens are real and they are here for
now the Brazilian military and
government deny everything and if the
Brazilian government is working with the
United States on a cover-up well they're
learning from the best
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ that's cycle fish
this has been the waffle house if you
had fun or learned anything do us a
favor like comment subscribe share that
stuff really helps the channel and like
most topics we cover here today's was
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the yfiles.com tips a special thanks
to our patrons who make all this
possible without our patreon members
there would be no Wipeout so I thank you
guys with all my heart if you'd like to
join a great Community Check out the
y-files Discord it's free but if you'd
like to support the channel consider
becoming a member on patreon you can
support for as little as three dollars a
month or grab something from the Wi-Fi
store
not to infect you with a toxic alien
poison is that true well I can't
guarantee it but but they're most likely
safe and I can live with that that's
gonna do it until next time be safe be
kind and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
foreign